[Music]
over the past century astronomers have
speculated about the existence of a
mysterious ninth planet lurking in the
outer reaches of our solar system
although we've never directly observed
the elusive Planet X researchers keep
finding more strange phenomena that seem
to support its existence
if this giant planet exists what does it
look like and how could it change our
understanding of space itself this is
what if and here's what would happen if
Planet X was real scientists believe
that Planet X also referred to as Planet
9 is about 17 times bigger than Earth
and made entirely of gas you'd think it
would be easy to spot something so big
but it orbits the Sun about 10 to 20
times farther away than Pluto finding
this planet would teach us more about
how solar systems evolved but could it
also bring about the end of days so far
our hunt for Planet X has been mostly
based around the idea of if there's
smoke there's fire and in this case the
smoke is a bunch of weird things going
on amongst the stars
in 1972 astronomers noticed some
irregularities in the course of Halley's
Comet detours that they figured were
caused by the gravitational pull of an
unseen distant planet fast-forward 10
years to 1982 when scientists were once
again forced to consider the existence
of a hidden planet they hypothesized
that an unknown outer planet could be
orbiting within our solar system and
causing the orbits of Uranus and Neptune
to deviate from the laws of physics but
the most concrete evidence came in 2014
when astronomers noticed some distant
dwarf planets and icy objects that all
seem to follow orbits that cluster
together upon closer inspection they
estimated that the powerful
gravitational pull of a hidden planet
must have been the cause of these
unusual orbits so with all these signs
pointing to the existence and location
of Planet X why haven't we been able to
see it yet well it's really really far
away
and out in space things get dark pretty
fast the intensity of the sun's light
weakens by a factor of four going out
and then four times again reflecting
back to put that in perspective a planet
that's twice as far away as our moon
would be sixteen times fainter on top of
that the planet could be lost in the
light pollution of the Milky Way or the
glare of a bright star but with modern
technology astronomers believe we'll be
able to find Planet X in ten to fifteen
years the leading team in California
uses one of the most powerful telescopes
in the world and has released a map of
where to look to increase the chances of
finding it through crowd-sourced
astronomy if Planet X is real it would
redefine our knowledge of our solar
systems evolution and give us key
insights into how other solar systems
are formed throughout the universe for
as long as serious scientists have been
looking at Planet X there have been
others who have proclaimed that it's
strange orbit will eventually collide
with earth but this has been rejected as
nothing more than pseudoscience and an
Internet hoax scientists say that Planet
X would be kept well beyond Neptune
throughout its orbit even when it's
closest to the Sun so even though we
can't see it it doesn't mean our ninth
planet isn't there maybe one day we'll
develop technology that can identify
worlds even further out than Planet X
but that's a topic for another what-if
[Music]
you